I.
Well, hello there, how are you?
I'm good, how are you doing?
I'm good.
Is Alex in or is traveling?
He is in, but I heard him. He might be on another call, but he should be joining us.
OK, no.
That's fine.
I will have another gentleman joining us today. Aman, he had to go through a surgery, minor surgery that is, yeah. So he's on bed rest for the entire week. They'll have Ashish, who is also one of my technical team that is joining us today.
Oh.
On the call.
Okay.
You should be dialing in shortly.
Ashish.
Hello, Mister. Hello, Ketan. How are you?
Hello, good, how are you?
Been great, thank you so much for asking.
Shall we get started, Karen, or we give it a minute for Aleks to join?
Let's give it a minute for Aleks to join.
Sure, how are things going?
Um, they're good.
So, you are working on the 3rd, this Friday.
No.
Hey.
How is the team doing overall, Karen?
Um...
I just heard one complaint.
So far, but...
With one complaint is, yeah, wanting for us. Is it someone from a specific or in general?
Well, I was telling Alex our one client, Yvonne Ward, she was not happy. I think it was Vincent working on the ticket and it took him a long time to fix the issue.
Bye.
At least she thought it took him longer than it should have, but...
Okay, is there a way you can you can share the ticket number with us? Probably we can we can have a quick look to see where we can do the coaching piece.
I don't know.
Alex said he cancelled and declined.
Today? Okay, there was another call that we go on that is a more strategic meeting that happens on the same day about a couple of hours ago, so probably that. But it's fine. I mean, if he's not able to take some time out to join this one, it's okay. Karen, I would need your help to...
help us with the ticket number or the ticket details for that specific issue so that we understand where he could have done better.
And that's where, you know, Ashish or Aman will come into play.
Let me.
Let me see if I can find it. Hold on.
Sure.
Yeah. Alex is telling me the whole meeting should be canceled.
As he wishes, we will, yeah, but now that I have with have time, we will, yeah, if it is just one thing that we can do and rest, I think we're good, Karen, right? Anything else from you that you want to cover today?
No, I don't think so.
OK, and on the 3rd Ashish who are working, it's animation.
It's animation and summer.
I think it's Vincent. Oh, I thought it was Vincent.
No, it wasn't Vincent. There was a there was a miscommunication, so I reached out to Aman, right? He forwarded the chat chat conversation that he had with Alex earlier. It was Summer and Animesh, because Vincent already had a planned leave for the on that day.
OK.
So yeah, and I think it was already communicated to Alex, but yeah, could be right. Okay, cool. I think we're good. Thank you for your time. Yeah, and one, just one thing, do remember to give us the ticket number, please, or some details about that feedback. Even if you could drop me in chat, that'll be great so that we can work with Vincent to make sure that there's.
Okay, yep.
All right. Sounds good. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
does not happen again.
Okay.
Okay, all right, cool. Thank you. Take care. Bye-bye.
Yeah.
You're welcome. Bye.
Thank you so much, Karen.
Yep, bye.
Bye.